the facts ma'am that's what we do Joe
Friday get the gnome hospitalization
rate takes down good news
net change down that's good news
intubation is down that's good news
covet hospitalizations new ones per day
just about flat that's not great news
actually up a tick so that is not good
news what we're watching now is how fast
the decline how low does it go we don't
want to see 1,000 new cases every day
we'd like to see that in the low
hundreds ideally of new cases every day
death rate terrible news 330 you see the
decline has been slow at best and still
disgustingly high so we're making
progress that's for sure but we're not
out of the woods yet
and we're proceeding with caution and
there are caution signs out there that
we should pay attention to Singapore is
talking about a second wave with 900 new
cases this is after they controlled the
beast they're on the decline they're now
looking at new cases Germany is a
situation that we should also watch and
learn from they relaxed and started to
reopen they are now seeing an increase
and these are interesting the rate of
infection which is what we watch was at
0.7 one person infecting 0.7 of a people
percent obviously less than one person
1% infection rate is one person
infecting one person they were at point
seven they started to reopen in ten days
they went up to a one on the infection
rate that's that's troubling shows you
how fast the infection rate can increase
if you don't do it right on the
reopening so proceed with caution
our reopening is different we don't have
a conceptual plan we don't have an
abstract plan because there is no
conceptual plan there is no abstract
plan you have to have a plan that is
based on facts based on specifics this
is not about politics this is not about
spin this is not about emotion there are
no conspiracy theories at work here we
outlined a 12-step plan that is factual
that is based on numbers based on data
and then it has a numerical circuit
breaker that is not subject to personal
emotion or desire but just checks and
monitors that infection rate that we
just saw in Germany and is watching for
those increases and if there's an
increase circuit breaker stops the
reopening at that point some of the
specifics we're looking at you must have
30 percent of your hospital beds
available we can't go back to where we
were where we overwhelm the hospital
system we have to have a 30 percent
buffer we have to have 30 percent of ICU
beds we have to have that buffer before
we start bumping up against total
capacity and we have to watch the
hospitalization rate and the diagnostic
testing rate how many are positive how
many are negative which will take on a
continuous basis you see that number
start going up worried but it's all
based on the data and the numbers I'm
sorry and the rate of an transmission
ort rate of transmission I wrote on
track rate of transmission
has to be 1.1 or less we just said
Germany is at point 1 because the one
point 1 that is textbook outbreak so
watch the numbers and watch the
transmission rate and how do you do that
you do that with testing right and
that's why everybody's talking about
testing the testing allows you to
continually test sample how many people
how many how many people positive how
many people are negative you see the
positive start to increase through your
day to day testing that is a pause sign
we were about doing about 20,000 tests
we said we wanted to double that we're
now on average about 30,000 tests per
day which is a dramatic increase not
where we need to be but a dramatic
increase where we are now you should
know is New York State is doing more
than most countries are doing so we have
been very aggressive in testing and we
have made great progress and New Yorkers
should feel good about that but we have
more to do on elective surgeries we had
canceled all elective surgery so we
could have increased capacity in the
hospitals when you cancel all elective
surgeries hospitals feel financial pinch
because that's where they make their
money is on elective surgeries so for
areas that don't have a fear of a covert
surge we're going to allow elective
surgeries to begin that's primarily in
counties upstate again counties where
we're still worried about a surge in the
kovat beds we're not going to open it up
to elective surgery until we know we're
out of the woods on the kovat virus and
this is a list of counties that are
eligible now for elective surgeries I'll
do an executive order on that today
we've been worried about frontline
workers because they are the heroes who
are out there every day so everybody
else can stay home somebody asked me
yesterday on a radio interview
well you know you're out there every day
are you taking care of yourself I'm out
there every day forget me I'll tell you
who's out there every day the nurses who
were an emergency room the doctors were
an emergency room the police officer is
who is going into homes and apartments
because there's a domestic disturbance
the EMTs the fire department the
delivery worker who goes 250 doors a day
and gets paid those people are out there
every day so they're the ones who are
really doing the work compared to them
what I do is de minimis and they're
doing it not because they get paid a lot
of money not because people say thank
you god bless you
they're doing it because it's their
value and their honor and their pride in
their dignity and they show up even when
it's hard they show up my hat is off to
them but I want to make sure that we do
what we need to do to protect them that
they have the equipment they have the
PPE they have our respect they have our
gratitude and I also want to make sure
we're testing so we get them the results
of tests so they can be taken care of
themselves I also want to see if we have
a significant problem in any of those
frontline workforces so we're doing
testing we started with the New York
City Fire Department and New York City
Police Department what we found so far
fire department which also has the EMTs
tested 17% positive NYPD 10% positive
number much higher in the FDNY EMTs we
believe that's because the EMT number is
driving it up but we have to do more
numbers and more research to determine
that remember the EMTs they are the
frontline they're the ones who are there
assisting the person in the closest
contact in many ways
FDNY also but we want to find out
exactly what's going on
though they compared to a downstate
average of the general population of
about 18% and again we'll do further
research further surveys to look at it
by race and gender also we're also going
to do the same thing with the transit
workers the people drive the buses the
subways who clean the buses in the
subways without those buses and subways
the essential workers couldn't get to
work why didn't we just closed down
subways and buses because you closed
down the subways and the buses in New
York City don't expect the nurses and
the doctors to be able to get to the
hospital
don't expect a delivery worker to be
able to deliver food when you ring on
your telephone so we need the that
public transportation to transport the
essential workers but those frontline
workers are at risk so we're going to do
additional testing for the transport
workers
I also commented yesterday the Daily
News had pictures of things that are
going on in the New York City subway
system where the cars were filthy they
would discuss thing homeless people were
there with all their belongings and it
was not just the Daily News picture it
reflected what has been in the press and
what people have been saying which is
the deterioration of the conditions in
the subways crime some crimes are up in
the subways even though ridership is
down 90% I don't even know how
mathematically that is possible
the trains are filled with homeless
people and you're not doing the homeless
any favor I've worked with the homeless
all my life to let homeless people stay
on the trains in the middle of a global
health pandemic with no masks no
protective equipment you're not helping
the homeless letting them endanger their
own life and endanger the lives of
others is not helping anyone so I told
the MTA yesterday in two days which
means tomorrow
I want a full plan how do we disinfect
every train every night period any
essential worker who shows up and gets
on a train should know that that train
was disinfected the night before we want
them to show up we don't want them to
stay home we owe it to them to be able
to say the train you ride the bus you
ride has been disinfected and is clean
also state and local funding from
Washington is essential this is now
turning into a political brawl on state
and local funding more and more some of
the elected officials in Washington are
saying they're against it they're led by
senator Mitch McConnell who leads the
Senate who makes it blatantly political
no blue state bailout no blue state
bailout what is he trying to say the
states that have coronavirus are
democratic states and he's a republican
so he doesn't want to help the
democratic states he went so far as to
say well he'd be in favor of the states
going bankrupt first states have never
gone bankrupt the states can't go
bankrupt there were serious
constitutional questions about whether
or not a state can go bankrupt declare
bankruptcy and you need a federal law
that would allow the states to declare
bankruptcy even if you got around the
constitutional question on bankruptcy so
if he believed that if it wasn't just
political rhetoric and personal vitriol
then pass a law that allows States to
declare bankruptcy
he would have to do that and I dare him
to do that and get that bill signed by
the president so
but to make it partisan is what is most
disturbing and you can see there now
rallying the partisan troops senator
Scott from Florida says we're supposed
to bail them out
we versus them we're supposed to bail
them out
it's we and it's them that's not right
who is we and who is them who is we and
who is them them the people who had
coronavirus they are the ones who had
the coronavirus we without the virus are
supposed to bail out those people who
have the virus what an ugly sentiment
first of all on the facts it's not even
close to right and why they would even
want to go down this road when the facts
damn everything they're saying and there
are still facts I know it's hard to
communicate facts in this environment I
know a lot of the filters don't
communicate facts they all communicate
spin now everybody has their own spin
but there are spells still facts that
are not political theater right New York
State bails them out every year not
bailing us out we bail them out every
year New York state pays twenty nine
billion dollars into that federal pot
twenty-nine billion more every year that
we never get back our state contribution
into the federal pot the United States
of America pot every year we put in
twenty nine billion dollars more than we
take out on the other hand they take out
every year
seven billion dollars more than they pay
to the federal government senator Mitch
McConnell you are bailing out in New
York when every year you take out more
from the kitty the federal pot 37
billion dollars more than you put in
who is bailing out who senator scott
florida you're gonna bail us out you
take out 30 billion dollars more every
year than you paying how dare they
how dare they when those are the facts
how long are you gonna play the American
people and assume they're stupid they
are not and they can add and they know
facts and I don't care what the news
media tries to do to distort these facts
they are numbers and they are facts and
they can't be distorted and this is
every year and look what it's really
about it's the Washington doublespeak
you look at the bills that they want to
pass and who they want to help they want
to fund the hotel's the restaurants the
airlines the big corporations that's
what they want to find well who does
state and local governments fund state
and local governments fund police
firefighters nurses schoolteachers food
banks that's who I want to fund and
that's what it means to fund a state and
local government and that's the choice
that they're making everybody applauds
the health care workers jets flyover and
tribute to the health care workers
that's all nice saying thank you is nice
how about actually rewarding them and
making their life easier
how about giving them hazard pay how
about helping with their child care how
about help
families who can't feed their kids right
now how about helping the police and
helping the firefighters and all the
people who are out there right now
killing themselves to make life easier
for us that's what this is really about
they want to fund corporate America
that's who puts money in their pockets
and I say let's fund working Americans
that's the choice
bailout us them now it's just theater
it's just smoke and mirrors to avoid the
American people seeing the reality which
is whose pocket they want to put money
in versus whose pocket state and local
governments want to fund the reason it's
so disturbing to me I'm not surprised by
anything in politics I've seen the good
the bad and the ugly for many many years
I was in Washington for eight years I
know what it's like but there was if
there was ever a time that one could
reasonably believe you could put aside
partisan politics if it was ever going
to be a moment where we could say you
know what let's stop just for one moment
the partisanship the ugliness the anger
the deception let's just stop for one
moment if there was going to be a one
moment to hit the pause button the
moment would be now you have human
suffering your people dying you can't
stop the politics even in this moment
even in this moment where people are
dying all across the country you still
want to play your politics that's what
this is about and that's why it is so
disturbed
on a fundamental level politics I'm
getting up and I'm reading that death
toll number I'm speaking to the widows
and the brothers and the sisters and the
children of people who died and then
we're going to play politics with
funding that's necessary to save
people's lives I mean when does it stop
and that this connect is between the
political leadership and the people
because the American people it's not
them they are principled they are kind
they are better than what they are
getting the American instinct is to help
each other in crisis the American
instinct is to be good neighbors the
American instinct was the farmer who
sent me the one mask to help a New
Yorker when he only had five masks and a
wife with one long and underlying
illness and he sends one of his five
masks to New York
think about that generosity that charity
that spirit that's America why because
we're good neighbors because we care
about one another
America was when I said we need help in
our emergency rooms and hospitals and
95,000
nurses and doctors from across the
nation said we will come to New York to
help will come in to the emergency room
will come in to the hospital I
understand it's covered
I'll leave my family and I'll come to
help yours that's America that's who we
are and that's who we have shown
ourselves to be in the middle of this
crisis the crisis brings out the best in
the worst yes and the best of
America is beautiful and that's what
we've seen because yes we are tough yes
we are smart yes were disciplined just
were United
yes we're loving loving because we are
Americans and that's who we are and how
we are as Americans and I just hope the
political leadership of this nation
understands how good we are as a people
and the text book says politicians lead
elected officials lead no sometimes the
people lead and the politicians follow
and that's where we are today follow the
American people look at what they're
doing look at how they're reacting and
politicians try to be half as good as
the American people I'm going to show
you a self-portrait that was done by
American people this is a self-portrait
okay
that's the self-portrait of America and
you know it spells it spells love that's
what it spells you have to look
carefully but that's what the American
people are saying we received thousands
of masks from all across America
unsolicited in the mail
homemade creative personal with
beautiful notes from all across the
country literally just saying thinking
about you we care we love you we want to
help and this is just people's way of
saying we can and we want to help this
is what this country is about and this
is what Americans are about a little bit
more of this and a little bit less of
the partisanship and the ugliness and
this country would be a better place
thank you thank you guys
of course news Bernadette I said the I
said when people get into the train in
the morning they had to know that that
train was disinfected the night before I
don't know I told the MTA give me a plan
whereby you will clean and disinfect
every train every night so that I can
say to the essential workers who are
killing themselves for our state we are
keeping the subways open for you and
when you get on the subway in the
morning or in the afternoon know that
that car was disinfected the night
before it's realistic it's an essential
how realistic is it what is the
alternative essential workers go to work
by the way you may get infected with the
corona virus on the train on the way to
work that's not realistic I'm not going
to do that we have been started
it is a tremendous undertaking that has
never been done before and you're going
to have to get homeless people into
shelters where they can get housing and
the services they need so that's a
second operation and the MTA has been
going back and forth with the NYPD about
this for weeks and weeks and weeks
the MTA hired private security guards to
help but all a private security guard
can do is call 3-1-1 which is the city
hotline which then has them called the
NYPD who are there in the first place so
the MTA's story is they're at their
wit's end but what I said is look I
don't care I don't care who's to blame I
don't want to point fingers I don't care
I'm at a place where
I'm dealing with people losing their
lives every day
okay I just want to get it done and I
will get it done just tell me what I
need to do to get it done let's start
telling the truth let's stop with this
filters and everyone covering their own
rear end and people skewing facts to
cover their own rear end and let's start
telling the truth the blunt truth and if
it makes some people unhappy that's the
way it's going to be but it has to stop
the trains have to be clean the homeless
need the services that they need and we
have to be able to do it as a society we
have to tell me what it takes to clean
the trains and disinfect the trains so I
know that I can say to the essential
workers it's safe to go on those trains
[Music]
I'm not gonna do a cleaning schedule I
don't do that I told them give me a plan
as to how to make sure every train is
cleaned so that when the train comes in
in the morning it is cleaned it's their
job to figure out the schedule and how
they do it but however it has to be done
I will do whatever I have to do to make
that happen you can't be in a position
where you say we're gonna send the plane
tribute to the nurses and we're going to
applaud the nurses at Elmhurst Hospital
and yesterday I got out of my car and I
applauded the nurses in Syracuse and the
doctors in Syracuse and I said on behalf
of every New Yorker I thank you from the
bottom of my heart for what you did on
behalf of every New Yorker I believe
that
but then on the at the same time if
that's what you believe well then help
them and you know that they're getting
on the subways to go to work make sure
the subways are clean
homeless people should be in check look
I've been working on the homeless issue
Bernadette
I've been working on the homeless issue
since I was 20-something years old I did
the first plan for Mayor David Dinkins
on how to help the homeless in New York
City Mayor Dinkins accepted it next
mayor was really Giuliani he came in he
accepted it we made tremendous progress
on the homeless I then went to
Washington I did a homeless plan for
Bill Clinton for the nation on how to
help the homeless he accepted it we
implemented it it made tremendous
progress it was called the continuum of
care this federal government still is
operating the program we have done this
before this is no false this is a false
choice well the homeless are on the
trains they have a right to be on the
train no one wants to live their lives
on a subway train and we have a higher
obligation as a society than to say okay
you can sleep in a subway car no you
deserve a shelter that is safe and
services if you need them to help you
improve your life that's what we should
offer and that's what we will
infinity action what facility from Sur
one major source of controversy has been
your policy okay we've done that just
let me give let me let me give you the
fact okay cuz facts we're talking about
facts you can have an opinion but you
can't have your own facts right Senator
Daniel Patrick Moynihan a nursing home
takes a covered person if capital i
capital F if they can adequately care
for that person if they cannot
adequately care for that person they say
I can't adequately care for a covered
person fine either they transfer that
person to a different facility or they
transfer the Department of Health and
say we have to transfer that person
we have other facilities we have covered
only overflow facilities just what
you're talking about we have it we've
discussed this so we can do that but it
starts with their determination they
have to say I can't provide for this
person as long as they say I can't
provide for this person and by the way
nobody even asks why it's just I can't
provide for this person okay we'll take
the person and we have overflow
facilities Nick governor and maybe this
is a question for
commissioner Zucker there's a Department
of Health guidance that essentially
allows asymptomatic nursing home
staffers to work with covent positive
patients some local officials are
raising some concerns with this because
it means people are still going to work
while they're asymptomatic and are coded
positive is there any concern that you
have with nursing home staffers still
going to work even though they've tested
positive for chrono virus so the
patients who are your question about
being asymptomatic we make sure they
have the necessary precautions that they
need if they're going in there to care
for other individuals there and that it
was all the PPE and we monitor them and
we're working on a way to test and we
are testing individuals who are in the
nursing homes both the workers as well
as the patients we are looking we are
looking at those numbers
[Music]
governor hashtag extend the lockdown is
trending on Twitter today yesterday you
said one of your fears was that one of
your fears early on was that essential
workers would not go to work out of fear
of coronavirus as you get ready to open
businesses in the state are you worried
that the next round of workers will not
want to go back to work will be will be
fearful of going back to work I just I
understand the question
extend the lockdown is trending meaning
people want to extend the lockdown and
not open up yes okay last week your
question was we had two protests outside
people wanted to go to work and I was
oppressing people by keeping them in
lockdown so today I'm not that I'm May
artificially open the lockdown they want
it to go back to work and these people
are saying they don't want to go back to
they are fearful they're still fearful
of so we have people last week
protesting because they want to go back
to work this week we have people
protesting because they don't want to go
back to work yeah welcome to America
that's right you have some people who
say they want to go back to work
liberate democracy
you have other people who say I don't
want to go back to work I want to live
yes what I'm saying is I hear both
voices I hear the politics
I feel the tension I get the tension
let's decide on the facts because this
is emotion on both sides right and I get
the emotion because this is an emotional
time
everybody's under stress everybody's
anxious mental health issues away up
domestic violence is way up alcoholism
is way up substance abuse is way up
people are anxious these decisions we
have to make without emotion and we have
to make them on the facts and I'm not
gonna be swayed this week by this one
and now the next week by the other one
make the decisions on the facts make the
decisions on the numbers I laid out
yesterday 12 steps first plan that we've
ever seen on the numbers you can reopen
if you don't increase hospitalizations
and you don't increase the infection
rate because you can overwhelm the
hospital what does that mean here are
the numbers here are the numbers and
we'll make the decision on the numbers
we've said from day one follow the data
follow
may not be able to get those employees
back so is there a way to deal with that
if a business tries to reopen and then
they can't get their workers back to
function forced labor
are they family members I think you
might've mentioned that yesterday our
frontline workers do we know who these
people Marina I don't know that we have
a statistical breakdown the thousand
people are troubling to me for all the
progress we made I mean just put it in
perspective if I came in here one day
and said we have a thousand people who
tested positive for the kovat virus
you'd say Wow in one day yeah so it is
startling news the only thing that makes
it less startling is that relative to
everything we've gone through it's
relatively positive news I don't know
that we have any data though they're
predominantly downstate New York where
they track the statewide numbers
predominantly downstate western New York
upstate but I don't know if we have any
breakdown of who they are where they
come in region so we know which
hospitals they're going into but not
necessarily people's occupations the
governor announced a couple of weeks ago
a study with the University Albany the
Department of Health on diagnostic
testing to collect a lot more
demographic data so we know who's
getting tested who's positive that
doesn't necessarily result in
hospitalization rates but it will give
us a better sense of who's testing
positive in the state that's not ready
yet they just begun that study
the state when many other states since
then have responded swifter look what's
one thing you would change about New
York's initial response going forward
just based on what we know now as a
lesson learned yeah I said at the time
New York was the fastest state to shut
down we went from our first case to
total shutdown in nineteen days
that's that at the time was the fastest
shutdown since then other states that
came later that saw what was going on
Saratoga Falls so some individual
hospitals if they have to they have to
meet the governor's criteria the
criteria that established by the
department Health which is 30 percent
that capacity overall 30 percent ICU bed
capacity and then not an uptick in a
number of kovat patients per day so some
of the individual hospitals don't meet
one of those tests and some of the
counties haven't met that test so that's
why you see some of the differences in
the region's just based on the
hospitalizations of those specific
regions right the issue is the theory
they have the tech capacity they have if
there are emerging issues where they
think they do have the capacity the
Department of Health has established an
exemption policy but they want to review
that to make sure that there is actual
capacity at those hospitals because you
don't want to OB overwhelm so what
they're seeing in that data are
increases in hospitalizations
potentially so we want to make sure that
those beds are available as potential
infections increase
yeah the this was into the our new
concept of attractive nuisance
although the lawyers would say this is a
improper use of the term which it is
what would just bother the bother the
lawyers a little bit you can't open an
attraction that could bring people from
across the state to that attraction and
overwhelm a region State Fair in
Syracuse Saratoga racetrack
I don't think we have time first of all
but today I don't think you can open
those unless we do it statewide because
there is such a pent up demand to get
out of the house and do something you
open the Saratoga racetrack I guarantee
you have the highest attendance in the
history of the Saratoga racetrack you
will have people from the entire
Northeast region driving to the Saratoga
racetrack just because they want to get
out of the house anymore yes now you
could say well that's great for the
Saratoga racetrack but density is not
our friend right even when you talk
about opening a venue you look at some
of the pictures of some of the states
that are opening venues two seats apart
six feet six feet apart you know how do
you do six feet apart at the racetrack
how do you do six feet apart at the
State Fair how do you do six feet apart
at the racetrack of the State Fair when
you have double the attendance you've
ever had and people are all crammed in
there you know so I think it would have
to be a state wide opening coordinated
with Connecticut coordinate with Jersey
otherwise you will have a much much more
dense situation if you wind up being the
only attraction in town and town is a
tri-state region let me just make sure I
put an exclamation point in a point that
I was trying to make earlier this
political
patina this politicalization
of what we're going through in this
country is extraordinarily dangerous we
are dealing with probably the most
dramatic situation we've dealt with in
modern political history we're dealing
with a situation that we don't really
understand and we don't know how to deal
with this is all uncharted water I've
talked to every expert on the globe
nobody has been here before it's going
to take us at our best to navigate this
to save lives at our best at our best we
have to be working together we have to
be logical we have to be cooperative we
have to be sane we have to work with
people who sometimes we don't like we
have to work across the aisle we have to
be at our best when you start to
politicize this situation and you start
to say red and blue and this team in
that team you may as well take a wedge
and hammer it right into the middle of
this country and if you do that during
this time and this becomes a political
football or closing an opening becomes a
political football or funding becomes a
political football or this becomes a
finger pointing blame game and you
divide this country the worst could lie
ahead we think we're coming out of it
but that's only if we do what we have to
do and what you hear coming out of
Washington and I was there for eight
years I've heard this music before this
is the music of a campaign season this
is a music of a rally and balloons and
it's us versus them and we're good and
they're bad and that is poison right now
as to where we are thank you guys